[Music]
so I so why the long break I guess it's
a question that a lot of people have
been at or the people who watch have
been asking and it's the first time
we've done anything like this first time
I've been anything like this I guess let
me answer that by starting off with what
might my day-to-day look like before
listen to NPR MSNBC the crap like that I
know know what people who disagree with
me are saying
unfortunately it being the first thing
to greet you in the morning can grow to
be grating
[Music]
80 milligrams left me
[Music]
and you see you know the doctor was his
lab coat kind of a notepad and pen it's
Bill O'Reilly looking at the camera
smiling and then we're gonna zoom out
dressed as a nurse swallowing a baby
it's gonna be the Bill Cosby face
[Music]
the authorities suspect no foul play
they were just think of a Photoshop of
her by the bed and you know Bill
O'Reilly with his clipboard and pen
smiling and then you zoom out this
clearly a woman nurse with Bill Cosby's
face you know Bill Cosby faces
[Music]
and then we'd always hit this log jam
right have to go and try and take these
sketches that you see on the show at
that same time try to help with the
research and the diving segments try and
scramble to get some lunch in shower
then would be taping the show and then
after that show I would be pre-taping
sketches or interviews or debates
whatever maybe that day until sometimes
like 6 7 o'clock at night and with
without a break and I did that on this
show really four to two years entirely
before that this show was around on
radio it was a three hour show once a
week and this show is really what I'm
most passionate about I love doing it
so it wasn't this this break of Oh
throwing my hands up and and not wanting
to do it it was you know with the health
problems the way to describe it would be
really wanting to do this something that
you love it's really the only thing you
ever wanted to do and you just not
you're just not able to do it it was
went to a doctor and said you can't do
this you're gonna write if you if you
keep going at this pace you're gonna die
pretty much like 4050 years old in other
words too early not soon but too early
for me and so along with with kind of
fixing myself up and making sure that I
made some corrective decisions were
really fortunate have a great team of
people some new hires who've come in who
have really placed an emphasis on
getting healthy and make sure that this
is something that we all continue to
love to do and that we're all able to do
it the breaks that we've taken before
you know sometimes people said will have
been times when you haven't done shows
well like a prime example of that was
when we're doing an undercover sting
with antiphon because we had to go to
radio silence or we're on the road going
to change my mind at school so all the
stuff was happening simultaneously and
during all this you know we were moved
we're moving into this new space I think
I talked about we were to kind of do
this last year and then the lease fell
through at the last second so we had a
pod here which was highly illegal a
storage space a student that everything
was separate because we're kind of
slapping band-aids on
and we've just needed some time to
really to really gather our bearings and
make sure that we could do none of the
kind of show that we've been doing and
do it better but the kind of program
that that hasn't been done before people
who are performers you often you often
hear them say I've reached a point where
I just I just had to do it for me
and it sounds not only not only is it
disingenuous because art in any any form
is designed for an audience in this case
it's the fans it's you it's the people
who watch this it's the people who have
a program that means something to them
if if art doesn't mean anything to
anyone else then it doesn't mean
anything and so I can't say that I
wouldn't say oh I'm just doing this for
me I mean I love this this work I love
this team but we all do this for the
people to whom it matters most
[Music]
sometimes I'm kind of thinking out loud
but sometimes I wish I could answer that
more effectively though the why
I think the reason though that word that
I anyway kids before anyone else the
reason that I am coming back and I'm
going to hit the pavement as hard as I
can to make this show and this movement
as as best as possible
[Music]
the only answer I can think of to really
give you is that I can't not
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]